hi everyone it's joanna here today we
have a quick yet very effective
15-minute indoor bootcamp so this
workout will work on your upper body
lower body as well as your core strength
the good news is this workout is low
impact and you don't need any equipment
so you'll only need a mat and a very
small space to get this workout done so
let's do it
so we'll be moving up and down
throughout the entire workout
alternating between lower body as well
as your upper body and core okay so for
each workout will be 45 seconds long
with 15 seconds break in between
simple body weight movements yet
extremely effective okay so
the first workout is going to be an in
and out squat so start in a narrow
position point your toes forward squat
down
and as you step out
get
into a neutral squat okay in
and alternate your leg so that is the
first workout
right are we ready let's just shake it
out
and let's get straight into the 15
minutes
narrow position squat down push your
butt back step out
and squat so just allow your arms to
swing naturally
up
and narrow good
push your butt out
and bring your legs close together
sit back
try to go as low as you can
down
and out
good
so this is the first workout and this
can also be your warm-up
again all you need is a mat
and your own body to get moving all
right now let's get down onto the floor
okay the next workout is going to be a
back roll so get onto all fours
hover off the floor and all i want to do
is crawl forward
keeping your back flat
and crawl back
good job so remember to keep your butt
down keep your back flat
crawl forward
and back
so you should feel the work
on your core as well
as your upper body and not forgetting on
your legs as well so crawl forward
keeping a neutral spine
gaze onto the floor
and reverse the movement
forward
and back
if you have more space then by all means
you can crawl
further forward right step back up
next is going to be a forward and
reverse lunge so
you'll need to find your balance for
this workout okay start right in the
middle of the mat step forward
and
reverse the lunge
if you're struggling to balance
take a step in the middle step back take
a step and step forward
if not
go with me
forward
and push it back
so look at one focal point
and
brace your core
and just balance
your body good job
[Music]
just working on one side to begin with
okay
and on the second round we want to work
on the other
leg back
[Music]
and done all right now let's get down
onto the floor
let's start right at the edge of your
mat
what i'm going to do is give me
four mountain climbers
and slowly
walk
to the end of your mat
for climbers
and now slowly
walk
to the end of your mat good
so it's a plank walk
with climbers
remember
back flat
do not pick your butt up
pumps firmly onto
the mat
okay
two three
four
slowly
all the way
and now back
[Music]
and just drop it back down all right now
come back up
the next workout is going to be a side
to side shuffle okay again
start right at the edge of your mat all
i want to do is shuffle
tap
and shuffle so stay light
on your feet
shuffling to the right
and
to the left
tap down
and tap
good
so
we're not jumping
we're just staying light
on our feet
tap
and tap
good
remember to reach as low
as you can
[Music]
like on fire my heart is racing
just few more tap
that's one more
and
get back down all right
the next workout is going to be a
push-up with shoulder tab so
let's start easy let's do the push-up on
your knees to begin with so one
firm push-up
tap the opposite shoulder
and
push up
good
so gaze onto the floor
and remember to brace your car
avoid avoid
moving your hips
too much
just a slight movement
tap
down
and tap
good job push up
tap
a few more
you're almost there
looking strong
one more
and good job all right now
staying in this kneeling position
all i want you to do is
bring your right leg up okay we're going
to work with our left leg to begin with
all i want to do is step up
and back into the kneeling position so
it's going to be
a single leg
kneel to squat okay so we're going to
work on each leg for 30 seconds long you
should feel the burn
on
your
right leg the standing leg all right
i can feel it
up
stay low do not come all the way up
that's one more
and now switch side
right left leg up let's go tap
down
and
stay low good job
oh my gosh i know
this is the finisher
and this is the killer as well
gently tap
do not rest
your knees okay just gently tap and back
up
just a few more seconds
and come back up
okay
shake it
out all right
take a short break drink some water keep
yourself hydrated and we want to repeat
the entire workout once more
and i'll see you back here
[Music]
that was your first seven minute now we
want to repeat the entire circuit once
more and so let's give it your best shot
you know the workouts so i want your
best effort and your best energy okay
first workout narrow to a white squat
step
close toes pointer forward down
and out maintaining a low position
throughout keeping your knees soft
find your rhythm
pace your breathing
nice and easy down
and
try to squat lower each time
okay
down
good
push your butt back
chest up
look straight ahead
yep i see you
yup i'm feeling the glutes
filling on my quads
really feeling the burn on my lower body
down
and good job okay right at the edge of
your mat
back row get on to all fours
lift your knees off
are we ready let's go crawl forward
one step at a time
and crawl
back
okay
keeping your back flat
do not
pike
your butt up
look onto the floor
small
step forward
and small
step
back
everything is on fire right now
i don't even know
where it's hurting anymore
let's keep going
looking strong
and can back up okay now face the other
direction all right
so we want to switch to the other leg
remember
take a wide forward lunge and a white
reverse lunge are we ready let's go
forward lunge
and a reverse lunge
look at one focal point
brace your core
and just trust your body
move with your body
if at all you need to take a short break
step in the middle
get back into a reverse lunge
okay
good job
now you should feel the burn
on your left
leg
right forward
wide back
just few more
and check it out all right now let's get
down onto the mat
let's start right at the edge of your
mat so it's going to be plank walk
climbers okay four mountain climbers and
let's walk
one two three four
let's go
to the edge of a mat keeping your back
flat
all right
one step at a time
do the work
on your car
cool
and really
press into the ground
okay
maintaining a flat back
this indoor bootcamp is on fire baby
let's go
[Music]
and just
drop it down
oh my gosh
get back up
back to your lower body
side to side shuffle okay
let's start at the edge of your mat are
we ready stay low
shuffle tap
shuffle and tap
oh find your rhythm
and your pace
and as you tap down
keep your back flat
keep your chest up
all right push your butt back
[Music]
halfway there
oh
stay with me
i know
it's burning
last 10 seconds
okay
we're a team
we're going to do this and finish this
together one more
okay
good
now
get down
choose your option either on your knees
or on your toes okay
push up with
shoulder tap
are we ready let's go
on your toes push up
tap
tap good
nice solid push up
and tap it
[Music]
on right
remember to stabilize your hips
and minimize
the movements
from your hips
okay
slide your belly in
keeping
a flat back
a few more
oh my gosh when i'm not talking
you know that it's tough
ah
drop it down
okay
one
final workout
oh only 15 seconds 15 minutes and look
at me alright
single
leg new to a squat all right start with
your right leg
30 seconds on each side
and the whole goal here
is to
maintain
a low position so you are constantly
working on your right leg or your
standing leg okay the tension is
constantly there and that's what we want
stay low kneel back
good job
one more
and take a short break
switch to the other side are we ready
up
and back down so now the tension should
be on the opposite leg
almost there
oh
i know it's burning
10 more seconds remember don't just
collapse
gently tap onto the floor control your
movement down
tap
up
push
up
and stand back up
okay guys
very
very well done
that is the end of your 15-minute indoor
bootcamp
short
quick
effective and i'm feeling extremely good
my whole body is on fire right now my
legs are burning
my upper body
and my core so if you're ever short on
time or if you feel like getting a quick
workout done then be sure
to try out this workout and if you like
to combine it with other cardio workouts
or even strength training workouts do
check it out on my youtube channel well
if you haven't yet subscribed then what
are you doing go ahead and hit the
subscribe button and i will see you in
my next workout session let me know how
you felt in the comments below all the
best
[Music]
you